one guy who has been one of the most
physically gifted as it relates to
passing ability as uh quarterbacks go in
the past generation is drew brees he's
the current leader in all-time passing
yardage he's been out for six weeks now
and he's right on track mahomes may be
ridiculously ahead of schedule
brees right on schedule to be back six
weeks after injuring his thumb against
the rams he had surgery on that thumb
had a brace installed inside the thumb
and let's listen to brees explain
whether or not he will be back this
weekend when the saints host the arizona
cardinals
are you going to play this week that's
the plan
we'll see
what will go into your decision
is it your decision just making sure i
can be me
is it strictly your call or is it the
whole organization what would go into
the whole final decision to see if you
play i'll tell sean if i'm ready and
he'll believe me do you feel like you're
100 now i mean or
is that fair to say throwing the ball
we're getting there
oh he's going to play on sunday put me
down for drew brees is playing if he's
on your fantasy team get ready to put
him back in the lineup and get ready to
dump teddy bridgewater unless and until
brees gets injured again because i have
a feeling look i i was told a few weeks
ago that the cardinals game is the
target and
everything that and that little smile
that kind of knowing
understanding i think he's back on
sunday chris well the big thing is and i
understand drew brees wanting to come
back i mean of course he wants to play
and and he wants to get going himself
he'd probably like to get a game under
his belt before he starts the bye week
right to kind of just take that angs
away okay i got one under my belt got
some reps but but the big thing too
would be about his ability to practice
this week like if he can't full-fledge
go out and practice i'm not so sure i'd
want to throw him out there on sunday
you know again with a thumb injury it's
not easy to you know replicate playing
quarterback that way you're not going to
get a lot of full speed reps and make
all the throws you can because you're
dealing with that and i'm sure he's
getting close to it but with a bye week
coming i just look at it and go man is
arizona you're clearly the better team
and i understand arizona's on a little
roll and certainly a little more
dangerous than we thought but
i i would err here on just let's take it
through the bye week come back have a
really good full week of practice for
your next game and then we're on and
drew brees is back on it's the atlanta
falcons he can kick their butt and then
the saints are you know back to who
they're supposed to be
yeah the saints have two bye weeks they
have a bye week and then they have the
falcons but uh
and and look i mean falcons fans can't
be upset about that the team stinks this
year but i i
i think that the cardinals here's the
thing the cardinals are better than what
we thought they were a few weeks ago
they've won three in a row now they've
beaten three of the worst teams in the
league but still they're dangerous
potentially and maybe you can just ride
your defense and outscore them that way
but
here's the bottom line brees is going to
want to play and uh you know you put him
back out there and see what he can do
and they have doctors they can check him
out and and if he's confident that he's
ready to go he's ready to go how much
does he really need to practice chris i
mean the guy knows the offense inside
and out and sean payton will have a game
plan ready to go for drew brees you know
you know sean's capacity ready for
breeze we'll have a game plan ready for
bridgewater and however it goes it goes
yeah no yeah i mean you're right like
the mentality part of it the mental part
all those things i'm not worried about
drew brees in that in that capacity in
any in any shape way or form i mean he's
fine there but even still drew brees
first ballot hall of famer legend all of
that you know to not get full speed reps
during a week and then just go out and
play i don't care who you are that's
gonna be tough you know all of a sudden
oh wow i gotta throw like a 20-yard out
route and there's somebody in my face
and things like that you know those are
things you'd like to practice at least a
few times somewhat to replicate i know
you can't fully do that in practice on a
friday or a thursday uh you know to its
complete way as far as guys hitting you
but still you'd like to get that timing
that rhythm that feel of you know the
ball popping out of your hand to where
you know so hopefully on sunday when
that guy is wide open you don't miss the
throw because it's the first time you've
really gone oh let me put the pedal to
the metal here and throw a 20 yard out
route because i got to put this ball you
know on the money that's that's the
aspect i worry about more than anything
for a guy like drew brees mentally and
the game plan you're right he'll be all
over it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports